is the author of let the world see you
how to be real in a world full of fakes
oh my gosh uh sam macho here on the rich
eisenhower sam you must not live in los
angeles
i don't i don't even know my brother
just moved to l.a not too long ago so
i think i wrote the book for him in a
lot of ways emmanuel
well if there there might be some fakes
in his studio
i'll tell you that hey now is that wrong
to say
is that wrong saying maybe you're wet
there he went there i did go there
well i don't have to go there to work um
how are you sam
i'm doing great rich i'm doing great man
it's really good to be on with you
it is good to be on with you too why do
why why'd you write this book sam
let's walk through the door this way
yeah absolutely well i wrote this book
it's funny
people ask okay well was it something
you had planned on or something you
hoped to do honestly this book really
was birthed out of
uh pain it was birthed out of a time
where i
i just signed like a multi-year
multi-million dollar contract going on
my eighth year in the nfl and on the
outside things look like they were going
great i had made it in a lot of ways
but as the title says how to be real in
a world full of fakes let the world see
you i was
catching myself hiding not really
showing people the real me prime example
people who know me they know i love
learning education is like my thing i
got my mba while i was playing
from the thunderbird school of global
management the number one international
mba in the world
and i didn't tell anybody kept it a
secret for my teammates
coaches staff i don't want them to think
that i didn't fit into the
typical nfl uh you know mold
right right another another you know so
that's one way that i hit another way
that i hit really was like
people know like okay people know you
know i'm a christian too so it's like
while i'm on the field and i'm i'm
getting into fights with guys and i'm
competing
they're like whoa whoa whoa what is this
sam we haven't seen this before where
are you
so i would try to like try to hide this
you know i would get angry and i would
hide i'll try to hide right and so
funny enough week before training camp
2018 season chicago bears matt maggie
new coach
his motto that year actually was bu
i'm sitting down with one of my buddies
the week before training camp
and just telling them how yeah things
look good on the outside but on the
inside i'm i'm struggling man like i'm
not doing well
at all and i remember just i remember
just being in tears with this guy like
crying like man i don't know what's
going on like
i don't know what's going on he and he
looks at me and he says well sam
said and i i said i need to get back to
the football season right let me get i
got a week we'll get to training camp
season be
with the guys i'll be fine he says sam
if that's how you are right now
he said i'm afraid of what happens when
when football is over for you when you
retire
this is how you feel and and as i'm like
looking up and as i'm like crying like
wiping the tear away he looks at me he
says
and oh by the way sam it's nice to see
you
[Music]
and i'm thinking like what do you what
do you mean by that he said dude i've
known you for 10 years all i've seen is
the put together
right the million dollar smile guy who's
got it all together but it's good to see
that you are
human it's good to see you
and so that moment for me really was the
start of something new
in me right it started me showing people
who i really was actually started going
to counseling
a week later you recommended a counselor
i started talking to this counselor and
as i'm talking he said hey sam i got a
question for you
he says what do you do when you get
angry
and i look at him and i say well i just
i just don't get angry
he says well what do you mean what do
you do when you get angry
i said well i just i just try not to get
angry and he looked at me again he said
sam
everybody gets angry so what do you do
when you get angry i thought this was
going to be like a quick like one
meeting two times the beginning
he was like no man this is gonna be a
lot longer what do you do when you get
angry
and after you ask that question i start
to cry
and he looks at me in my tears and it
wasn't just like one of the little like
drops it was like
an ugly ugly cry and he looked at me in
my tears and all and he says
it's nice to see you sam
and so this book rich is really about
what it means to be seen
to be known and to be loved i think at
the end of the day what everybody really
wants is just to know that they're loved
appreciated right
talking about le'veon bell i'm talking
about jabal adams how about any of these
players who leave teams
right what do they what's the first
thing they say and i've been there
before
man it's good to go somewhere where i
where i'm valued where i'm appreciated
right it's not a football book right i
know my book let the world see you how
to be real in a world full of fakes it's
not a football book
it's a book for anybody who's ever felt
any kind of guilt shame doubt
uh fear right any of these emotions and
you're felt like you had to hide them
it's about what it means to be free
sam macho here on the rich eisen show so
um
are are you are you done are you retired
are you i don't know man i've been
training and i've been staying in shape
to stay ready but in all reality a lot
of my desires have changed right like
with this book
you mentioned like how did it come about
i didn't plan it right but that year a
lot happened right not only those
conversations but i remember
carrying my peg being out for the season
i remember having a really real passion
to do some social justice work and all
of a sudden since i had more time on my
hands
got a chance to get with the guys on the
bears and i only support my teammates to
play first time made the playoffs in
five ten years but also i got a chance
to help my team raise about a million
dollars to go towards social justice
stuff right so doing that
and the book came out i'm i'm going
speaking and letting people know about
this message about freedom and so
to answer your question if somebody
called i would definitely i would pick
up i don't know what i would say right
now
uh you know because i feel like god has
changed a lot of the desires of my heart
to something bigger than just football
well the reason why i ask
um is because you you brought up about
how
uh the conversation that led to this
book and led to uh
i guess an awakening might be a way to
to put it or a realization
uh was what's how are you gonna feel
like or what's gonna happen when you're
retired
and and that to me having been
associated with the nfl network since
2003
uh was one of the first things that was
impressed upon me
on my experiences of meeting players
getting to know
the men underneath the helmet and the
pads if you will
and realizing after years of just
sitting on a sports center set and being
just a fan watching a game on television
that these are human beings
you know these are human beings and and
many of the times we we find out about
the human beings
for the wrong reasons because that's
then that's that's when we see in the
headlines about
um you know an arrest or
um some sort of flouting of the law
when 99 of the men who play football
fathers and sons and sometimes like in
the case of five grandfathers and
and and and and community upstanding
people
who after four years of playing the
sport on average
after being a big man on campus like you
at the university of texas
have to figure out something else to do
because the career is over and
it is one of the most heartbreaking
things that i ever get to see
in person it's so difficult it's so but
we're seeing your brother he's crushing
it right now
there's no question about that um but
that's why i asked you if you're retired
to see
you know if this is what you want to do
this sort of conversation
or authoring or what have you and see
how your uh
if you will handling all of it yeah no
it definitely is
and even in the book i actually write
this chapter called the art of the pivot
how to handle life's transitions and and
i talked about this because as i was
writing though i still went back after
that 2018 season i got injured i got
released by the team the bears
i went back a few months later and
signed with tampa bay and played with
tampa bay last season and
with ba and the whole squad and but
something was different
something was different after kind of
coming to this realization that i'm more
than just
what i do that i'm more than just a
football player so yes i went back and
played this kind of an answer to your
question
this went back and played but my
reasoning was different right it wasn't
so much about
what's the biggest contract i can get or
you know how many how many cubies can i
sack it was more about okay how can i
make an impact on these guys on the
locker room because i've seen the stats
the same way you've seen them right
80 percent of guys after retirement and
this was that
outside at least when i came in or
either 80 or either divorce depressed or
bankrupt within three years after they
retired
and so my heart said yeah i don't like
that and i don't want that to be the
story for anybody
any of my teammates current former or
even future guys were going to play
in the nfl but even more in the nfl like
in life people hide
you know in businesses and bars and so
that's why i wrote the book right that's
why i wrote let the world see you it's
for anybody who's ever
gone through a transition who's going
through a transition who knows what it
feels like to hide
um but also with this idea that you
don't have to always jump even if you
know
like even for me like i knew i'm
starting to understand that football
right i'm i'm on your tent right so i'm
way past the average
uh football has a shorter lifespan
looking forward for me than others and
so yes i still may play if i get a call
my passion is really about helping
people be free and that's what i think
is shown in the book
sam acho here uh on the rich isaac show
i guess if you don't mind let's talk a
little bit of football
um and you know you you spent last year
with tampa
uh did you get a sense that uh the team
was
kicking tires on somebody other than
jameis at the end of the season
in the manner that we're we're learning
that they were already evaluating other
quarterbacks elsewhere did you get that
sense
yeah absolutely absolutely what i saw
last year the team started off i got
there i think the team was one and
six one and seven at the time i got
there week eight we ended up winning i
think seven out of our last nine games
which was positive but you could tell
the team was kind of saying we need
something or someone to help us get over
this hump and obviously the first
position you look at is the quarterback
and so i did get that sense that man yes
jameis
played really really well but the team
you know jason light the gm whether it
was ba
even defensive on the defensive side
with todd bowles it's like hey we need
somebody
right maybe it's quarterback maybe it's
tight end maybe it's guys on the
defensive defensive side of the ball
to really help us get over that hump
because anybody who knows ba knows b is
a winner he doesn't play around
right he's a winner right one of the
biggest things i remember playing with
them
in tampa bay and also in in arizona when
i play with arizona right
you start stacking those wins one in a
row two in a row three in a row right
this idea of momentum we see it
uh you know when he says you know they
remember what you do in december right
playoff teams right it's momentum and so
anyways to answer your question i did
get a sense that
the team was ready to go in a different
direction i didn't know it was going to
be tom brady
and i think the jury's still up and
seeing how that marriage is going to
work out with ba
in his mind about throwing it deep seven
to nine times the game and tom brady
in a lot of ways to check down king
we're still gonna see
how that's gonna work out but i did get
a sense that tampa bay is trying to win
and trying to win now
sam do you want to do this for a living
like uh analysis like is that something
that you'd be interested in
or no i know i'm good at it rich but i
don't know if i want to do it for a
living i mean i enjoy it i've been doing
a little bit of it and i
uh and i enjoy it um and i think what i
can provide is like the athlete
perspective right that's like it's so
easy to
like with mr risky everybody gets on the
tribute oh man ben's the guy this and
that it's like not so much deeper than
that right people are getting on
on on le'veon bell right jamal adams
they're saying these guys are
you know some people said they're
cancers and it's like dude hold on hold
on if you got two three four five six
seven players
saying the same thing i'm not just
saying about adam gates right it happens
from team to team
it's like maybe you should look at it
from a player's perspective so anyways
yeah this is some stuff i really enjoy
doing talking ball
uh encouraging people and just kind of
giving people a different mindset
a different point of view than what you
usually hear all right
and then uh again i guess if you don't
mind last thing for you uh
to uh diagnose
from afar what's going on with michael
thomas and the saints
what do you think is going on there yeah
that's really really interesting it's
funny when i was a free agent last year
i actually had a workout with the saints
and so i reached out to
i got some people from their player
personnel group reached out to me worked
out with the team
and i know a bunch of the guys on that
team really really well
i was actually really surprised when i
saw what i saw
with michael thomas and obviously i'm
not in that locker room now and i think
they have a tight locker room which is a
sign of a good team
not too much is going to get out but
what i do know is this right there's a
phrase people talk about power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
there's this idea that whether you're a
football player a tv personality
uh person in politics no matter what
field you're in
you start getting a little bit of power
and prestige
sometimes not all the time but
oftentimes it can get to your head
and so looking at michael thomas or
michael thomas
and what what happened last week with
that with you know getting a fight in
practice looking at earl thomas
right a guy played with in college look
at why he's not on a team right now
right you start wondering man
it's not necessarily about the people
it's more about what is the
the prestige oftentimes or the success
the fame it can really can really uh
i've heard it said that that money same
success it's a magnifying glass so it
can expose a lot of things and so i
think that's why
that's what we're seeing with michael
thomas but also that's why i really want
people to get it get their whole
get a hold of this book because it
really helps expose some of our
flaws our insecurities and help us get a
better grasp of how to handle them well
let the world see you how to be real in
a world of fake sam acho let's uh do
this more often if you do want to
you know um give a couple cents on the
football world and
well i'm more than happy to continue our
conversations we'll do that
awesome i'd absolutely love to rich
thank you you got it and let me know how
your brother
uses this book in his daily uh uh
business i
will i absolutely will okay great you
take care sam
all right sam actually at the san matra
twitter and instagram
you liked that video of course you did
check out more right here